Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一个令人兴奋的消息。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“通往经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Why might people from South Asian heritage feel overlooked in mental health or for that
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由Lisa亲自提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。为什么南亚裔人士在心理健康或身体健康护理方面会感到被忽视？我和今天的嘉宾Zainab Khan将探讨塑造南亚背景人群健康需求的独特社会、文化和家庭因素。我们还将讨论作为医疗保健提供者，我们能做些什么来提供更好、更有效的支持。希望这对你有帮助。你好，欢迎收听。我是Marianne博士，很高兴你能来。这个播客最让我喜欢的一点是，我能学到以前不知道的东西，这不仅对我作为播客主持人很有用，对我思考日常的临床心理学工作也很有帮助，因为我仍然是一名执业临床心理学家，我每天都在接触客户。
matter physical health care? My guest Zainab Khan and I are looking at the unique social, cultural and familial factors that shape the health needs of people from South Asian backgrounds. We're also covering what we can do as healthcare providers to provide better, more effective support. Hope you find this so useful. Hi, welcome along. I am Dr. Marianne and it's lovely to have you here. One of the things I have loved best about this podcast is the kind of learning stuff that I didn't know before and that is useful for me in being a provider of the podcast but also useful for me when I'm thinking about client work that I do because I'm still a practicing clinical psychologist. I still see clients. Every day
活到老学到老，保持好奇心非常重要。你可能因为是医疗保健提供者而收看本期节目，也可能因为你自己是南亚裔，希望获得认同感和被倾听的感觉。这正是我们制作本期播客的原因之一，因为Zainab本人意识到她自己并没有获得过这种体验。所以我希望你会觉得这很有用。如果你觉得有用，请给我点个赞，留个言。如果你在Spotify上收听，请给本期节目评分。如果你在Apple Podcast上收听，请评分并留下评论。我们稍后见。
is a school day and it's really important that we stay curious. You might be watching this episode because you're a health provider. You might be watching this episode because you are of South Asian descent yourself and you would like to kind of feel seen, feel heard. And this is really one of the reasons that we are doing this podcast episode because Zainab herself recognised that she didn't really have that experience herself. So I hope you will find it so useful. And if you do, please do drop me a like, do drop me a comment. If you're on Spotify, please do rate the episode. If you're listening on Apple podcast, please do rate and review. I'll look forward to catching up with you on the other side.
我想欢迎今天的嘉宾Zainab Khan。你好，Zainab。你好。非常感谢你能来，也感谢你通过LinkedIn联系我。非常感谢。我很高兴能来到这里。很高兴你能这么说。在录制前，我们准备节目时，曾讨论过你在大学学习时感受到的代表性问题，你能详细谈谈你的想法吗？是的，直到最后一年我才真正意识到这个问题，这主要是因为我当时已经确定了对心理学研究的兴趣，而我的一位临床心理学讲师谈了很多关于黑人和非裔加勒比裔视角的文化适宜护理，因为她本人就是那个族裔。
I just want to welcome along our guest for today, Zainab Khan. Hi, Zainab. Hi. Thank you so much for being here and for reaching out to me via LinkedIn. Very much. I'm really excited to be here. Oh, that's really nice for you to say. Just before we were speaking on camera and in the preparation for this episode, we were thinking about how represented you felt when you were studying at university could you tell us a little bit more about what you mean about by that? Yeah so it never really occurred to me as a thought until I reached sort of the final year I think it was mainly prompted because I'd sort of narrowed down an interest into doing research in psychology and one of my clinical
我想这让我意识到，在我的整个学位学习过程中，我没有见过任何长得像我的人，无论是教职员工、讲师还是研究人员。我在攻读学位期间还参加了一年的实习，同样，在我接触的工作人员中，也没有长得像我的人。我认为这让我想到，考虑到南亚文化中存在很多关于不谈论心理健康的污名，“心理学”甚至不是我们日常语言中使用的词汇，这是一个非常禁忌的话题。我认为打破这种局面的关键之一，
psychology lecturers was talking a lot about culturally appropriate care from a black and Afro-Caribbean perspective being that was her ethnicity herself. I think it sort of just made me think that I hadn't seen anyone that looked like me throughout my degree in regards to like staff, lecturers, researchers and I also did a placement year while I me throughout my degree in regards to like staff lecturers researchers and I also did a placement year while I was doing my degree and again within the staff that I liaised with there was no one that looked like me I think it just made me think that it would be given that culturally there's a lot of stigma that comes from South Asians around not talking about mental health and psychology isn't even a word that we use in our everyday language very taboo topic and I think one of the big things in breaking that
就是要在心理学领域看到像我这样南亚裔的代表，特别是在英国。显然我不是在谈论国际情况，因为当你出国时，显然会有很多不同的南亚代表，但特别是在英国，我确实没见过。即使在我自己接触心理健康服务的经历中，我也从未见过任何南亚裔背景的人。是的，谢谢，这非常非常重要。在录制之前，你说过在人口统计和监测表格方面，通常没有一个选项能让你觉得代表了你和你的背景。通常只会写“亚洲人”。这范围太广了，不是吗？因为它涵盖了印度、巴基斯坦、中国。这太庞大了。那么当我们说“南亚”时，我们具体指的是哪些地区？对我来说，当我在做自己的论文，目标人群是南亚女性时，我脑海中浮现的是三个主要的群体。当然，即使在南亚内部也有很多不同的地方，比如泰米尔人，还有印度人、巴基斯坦人。对我来说，我考虑的三大群体是印度人、巴基斯坦人和孟加拉人，因为对我而言，这是我在日常生活中遇到的三个最大的群体，而且我认为从统计学上讲，他们也是英国最大的群体。太好了，谢谢。你知道，收看或收听本期节目的人可能因为他们有这种背景，或者因为他们想更多地了解如何谈论感受、困扰以及让他们担忧的事情。
down is to see representation of people that look like me and are South Asian in the space of psychology especially within the UK obviously I'm not speaking about internationally because when you go abroad there's obviously lots of different um south asian representation but specifically within the uk i just haven't seen any and even with my own experience of engaging with any mental health services i have genuinely never seen anyone that's of a south asian heritage yeah thank you that's really really important and before we hit record you were saying that often in terms of demographics and monitoring forms, there won't be an option that feels like it represents you and your heritage. It will be just Asian. And that's kind of enormous, isn't it? Because that takes in India, that takes in
是的，从个人经验，以及我初步涉足针对这一人群的心理学研究来看，南亚文化中有一点非常不同。我是巴基斯坦裔，所以巴基斯坦和印度的文化习俗非常相似。但在我们的祖国，很多时候女性承担更多的家庭角色，她们通常比西方文化中的女性更顺从，这在这些文化中并不一定被视为坏事。我认为，当人们来到西方文化时，关于性别差异和弥合性别角色差距的讨论非常多，以至于这几乎被视为非常负面的事情。但有时在我们的文化中，
Pakistan, that takes in China. That's enormous. So what areas are we thinking about specifically when we say South Asia? For me when I was doing my own dissertation and my target population was South Asian women I sort of in my head the kind of three large ones that come to mind obviously even within South Asia there's so many different places you've got Tamil people you you've got indian pakistani for me the kind of three main ones i was considering were indian pakistani and bangladeshi because for me they're the three biggest ones i encounter within my everyday but also i think statistically they are also the biggest ones within the uk too lovely thank you and you know the people watching or listening to this episode might be doing so because they are of this heritage or because they're wanting to learn more about how to understand talking about feelings and kind of troubles and things that are concerning them?
承担这些家庭角色和性别角色并不是一件负面的事情。这并不是说女性不应该被赋权，只是传统上我们就是这样长大的。我从自己的论文中发现，我们获取新闻、信息来源和影响的方式有时略有不同。家庭影响在代际知识传递中起着巨大的作用，我在做论文时非常深刻地意识到了这一点。为了针对这一人群，有时主流的心理学知识传递方式并不奏效。我们不会自然地去拿传单，
Yeah, so speaking from even personal experience, but also just my kind of toe dip into psychological research with this target population one thing that's so different about South Asian culture specifically I mean I'm Pakistani with my heritage so Pakistan and India quite similar in terms of their cultural practices but naturally I mean like back in our our young countries a lot of the time women take on more domestic roles they're almost a lot more submissive in comparison which is not necessarily seen as a bad thing in those cultures I think often when you come to western cultures there's so much talk about like gender disparity and sort of bridging the gap between gender roles that it's almost seen like it's very negative but sometimes within our culture that's
也不会自然地去拿你在医生诊所里可能看到的东西。但当它来自宗教影响或家庭长辈时，特别是那些不是在英国出生、从其他国家移民过来的人，这可能成为他们获取信息的主要来源。如果通过这种渠道传达出“心理学知识不重要”或“心理健康不重要”的信息，那么这种观念就会代代相传。是的，这让我想起我在伯明翰CAMHS（儿童和青少年心理健康服务）工作时，我与许多孟加拉裔家庭合作，
not actually a negative thing to take on those sort of domestic roles within the house and the gender roles and things it's not to say that women shouldn't be empowered it's just traditionally that's how we're sort of brought up I guess and even one thing I found myself from doing my own dissertation is that where we get our news and our sources of information and our influences are sometimes slightly different so there's a huge play on family influence passing down knowledge through generations and I think that was something that I thought of massively when I was doing my dissertation of to target this population sometimes the mainstream way of passing through psychological knowledge doesn't work we don't naturally pick up leaflets we don't
我合作的一些年轻女性觉得这很成问题，因为她们的父母通常不会说英语，或者英语水平不足以真正理解她们的教育、她们的处境以及她们正在挣扎的事情，更不用说如何翻译她们所面临的概念了。我们几乎是在试图帮助她们弥合两个截然不同的生活。在家中，她们要遵循父母认可或理解的方式，同时又要试图融入非常西方、现代的亚裔英国文化。这对她们来说并不容易。这确实导致了许多心理健康问题，让她们怀疑真实的自己是谁。也许
naturally pick up and things that you see maybe in doctor surgeries but when it's coming from say religious influences or an elder in the family they're often especially ones that don't come from England that have migrated here from other countries that can be their like primary influence for sources of information and if it's coming through there that you know psychological knowledge isn't that important or like mental health isn't that important then that's going to be what stemmed sort of through generation to generation yeah and it's um it's making me kind of think back to when I was working in a heart of Birmingham CAMHS service and I was working with lots of families who were of Bangladeshi heritage and
她们在和朋友在一起时感到最充满活力，感到被理解，能够表现得更奔放，或者更无忧无虑。然后，她们可能也非常享受自己文化和家庭的某些方面，但发现这些方面受到了很大限制，她们内心感受到的无限潜力并不一定被拥抱。是的，从研究的角度来看，我在最后一年思考了很多，我认为南亚人在文献中代表性不足的原因之一是他们很难接触到。这不一定是任何人的错。更多是因为他们已经承受了很多污名，谈论任何与心理学和心理健康有关的事情都是禁忌话题。而且，如果由西方或白人研究人员接触他们，他们不太可能产生共鸣。所以我向导师提到，
some of the young women that I was working with there were really finding it problematic because often their parents didn't speak English or didn't speak English well enough to kind of be able to really get on board with their education, with where they were at, with the kind of things they were struggling with, but also how to translate the concepts that were coming up for them. And we were almost kind of trying to help them bridge two quite separate lives, it felt like. That at home, with that which their parents would approve of or understand, whilst also trying to slot into a really Western, modern, and modern Asian British culture as well. It was just not an easy fit for them. And it actually did lead to lots of mental health struggles and kind of wondering who the real them is. Perhaps
如果我例如走进清真寺或社区中心说我在做研究，我得到的反应和回应可能与白人同行去说我在做研究时完全不同。这几乎是被刻意回避的。这就是为什么我非常热衷于在心理学领域争取南亚代表，无论是通过临床服务还是通过研究，因为你无法通过社交媒体接触到这些参与者，你无法获得公平的代表性。因为很多南亚人——我在曼彻斯特一个叫Longsight的地方长大，那里南亚人占主导地位——大多数社区成员根本不上社交媒体，他们根本不知道
they feel most vibrantly alive when they are with their friends and they're feeling understood and they're able to be perhaps more exuberant or you know more carefree and then you know perhaps also really enjoying aspects of their culture and their family but finding that that's much more limited and that their I don't know their limitless potential that they feel within them is not necessarily embraced yeah I mean off the back of, I think from a research perspective, the one thing that I thought of a lot during my final year was when it comes to, I think one of the reasons why South Asians are quite underrepresented in literature is because they're just hard to reach. And it's not necessarily anyone's fault. It's more so they already have a lot of stigma and it's a taboo topic to talk about anything to do with psychology and mental health but then also to be approached by a western or a white caucasian researcher you're less likely to assimilate with each other so I think one of the things I mentioned to my supervisor was
他们永远不会发现研究招募信息，他们也不会回应。但如果有人在社区中心、清真寺、锡克教寺庙或任何聚会场所举办课程，这更有可能被视为可信的信息来源或值得参与的事情。是的，这确实值得深思，关于我们如何组建研究团队，并不是要否定或贬低任何背景的人的技能，而是思考真实性和尊重。如果我们确保研究团队中有这种背景的代表，那么成功招募研究参与者的机会可能会大大提高。
if I was to for example go into a mosque or a community center and say that I'm doing research I'd probably get a slightly different reaction and response than if a white Caucasian counterpart was to go in and say I'm doing research it's almost been very much shy away from that I mean that's why I'm very very like passionate about trying to get South Asian representation in the psychology field whether that's through like clinical services or even through research because you just you're not going to get to those participants through social media you're not going to get to the ones well a fair representation anyway because a lot of the south asians i mean i grew up in an area in manchester called long sight and that was very very heavily south asian dominant and most of those community members aren't on social media they've got no idea how
是的，完全正确。我认为在心理干预方面，我记得提到的一个兴趣点是针对黑人和非裔加勒比裔个体，主要是男性，即在理发店实施心理干预。这是在美国，那是她所做研究的一部分。这显然是为了再次掩盖不同文化中经常存在的污名，但重点是进入他们感到舒适的地方，而不是试图把他们带进临床环境，在那里人们感到不舒服。这再次让我想到，
they would never find research call outs recruitment callouts they're not going to respond to them but if someone was to hold classes within like a community center or a mosque or a gurdwara or any place of worship or place of gathering it's more likely to be believed as a credible source of information or a credible thing to participate in yeah it's definitely food for thought isn't it to think about how we're kind of putting together our research teams actually and not to discredit or disparage any of the skills of anybody with any background but thinking about actually authenticity and respect and you know the chance of actually successfully recruiting to research studies might be dramatically improved if we try to obviously make sure that we've got some representation
同样的方法也应该适用于南亚人。我认为，特别是当你查看关于南亚心理健康困难的许多统计数据时，我知道黑人、非裔加勒比裔和南亚人通常是比率最高的两个群体。但我认为，关于南亚人没有准确统计数据的另一个原因是，他们没有被视为一个独立的实体。我认为当你试图将整个亚洲，特别是像亚洲这样的大洲结合在一起时，每个国家之间的文化差异是如此巨大，以至于几乎不可能将它们全部同化为一个整体并获得准确的代表性。所以我认为，如果统计数据能真正代表亚洲内部的每个群体，
of that of that background within our research team yeah yeah exactly i think one of the in regards to say psychological interventions one of the like points of interest that i remember brought up this was in response to black and afro-caribbean individuals mainly men it was to do with implementing psychological interventions within barbershops this was in america and that was part of the research that she had done but it was to obviously kind of again mask that stigma that's so often heavily held within different cultures but it was about going into their places of comfort as opposed to trying to bring them into you know like clinical environments and where people don't feel that comfortable and that again made me think
我认为你得到的统计数据将与现在各种报告中看到的有很大不同。是的，非常有趣。如果我们考虑临床问题、运营服务并试图获得更好的参与度，比如减少爽约（DNA），增加出席率和更有用的临床干预，我记得实际上在周五下午邀请某人是不明智的，如果他们要去参加周五的祈祷，因为他们不一定想来，也不一定能抽出时间来。你能多谈谈这一点吗，Zainab？是的，我认为如果医疗保健提供者受过更多培训，更加关注文化，并被邀请从参与者和客户那里吸收知识，这将建立一种更平衡的关系。因为即使是像周五下午预约这样简单的事情，仅仅是不得不打电话取消、重新安排，
that the same really should be applied to South Asians I think especially when you look at a lot of the statistics around like South Asian mental health difficulties I know that Black and African Caribbean and also South Asians have two usually of the highest rates but I think one of the reasons why also there aren't actually very many accurate statistics around South Asians is because they're not seen as an entity by itself I think when you're trying to combine the whole of Asia especially a continent like Asia the cultural differences between literally every country is so stark that it's almost next to impossible to kind of assimilate them all into one and to get an accurate representation so i think if the statistics were really done represented to each
我知道很多人，甚至我自己，有时打那个电话都让人头疼。所以这又是在中间设置了另一个障碍。如果医疗保健提供者已经知道“好吧，对于这个穆斯林客户，周五下午他们没空”，那就不要在那天给他们预约。你只是减少了一个障碍，减少了他们需要做的一件事。你的爽约率肯定会比现在低得多。这听起来好像表格上应该有一个部分，当你填写时，询问“你绝对没空的时间”，然后你把它输入系统，这样你就能一次性搞定。是的，甚至像现在关于心理障碍或心理健康困难在不同文化中如何表现的话题，
population within angia i think the statistics you'd get would be largely different than what's seen in all the different reports nowadays yeah very very interesting stuff and if we're thinking about kind of clinical issues and running a service and trying to get better engagement of, you know, less DNAs and more show ups and more useful clinical interventions, I'm kind of remembering that actually it would be a bad idea to necessarily invite someone on a Friday afternoon if they knew you would go to Friday prayers because they are not going to necessarily want to come they're not going to be able to necessarily swing that to to come by could you tell us a little bit more about that Zainab? Yes I think if sort of healthcare providers are more trained to be more culturally attentive and almost be invited to soak up knowledge from the participants and from the clients that they're dealing with it would just make for a more balanced relationship because even something as simple as if you're given appointments on a Friday afternoon just the act of then having to ring up cancel it rearrange
对我个人而言，宗教起着巨大的作用，我知道我的很多社区成员，宗教是一个巨大的影响因素。我实际上通过我的论文工作发现，这真的应该被用作一种工具。所以简而言之，我知道世界卫生组织（WHO）建议女性母乳喂养一定时间。恰好这个建议
I know a lot of people even myself sometimes just making that phone call is such a headache so again it's just putting like another barrier in between that if healthcare providers already knew okay for this client who's muslim let's say friday afternoon they're not going to be available don't even bother making an appointment for them on that day you're just making one less barrier and one less thing that they need to to do it and you would definitely have a lot less dna's than they probably already do at the moment it almost feels like there should be a section on a on a form doesn't that when you're filling it in are there times that you definitely aren't available and then you just kind of put that in the system so that you you kind of get it right first time every time yeah and even just things like i mean it's such a largely spoken about topic now with
在《古兰经》中被逐字逐句地作为建议提及。这让我想到，例如，对于一个不是在英国出生、没有接受过西方教育，甚至不熟悉世界卫生组织这个组织的人来说，医疗保健提供者如果说“从文化上讲，如果你看你的宗教书籍《古兰经》，它逐字逐句地写着同样的内容”，那么对于某些人来说，来自该来源的影响力要比来自世界卫生组织的影响力大得多。绝对是这样。
regards to how say psychological disorders or mental health difficulties present in different cultures but even things like obviously for me personally religion plays a huge part and I know a lot of my like immediate community members religion is such a huge influence and I actually found through my dissertation work that really should be sort of almost used as a tool so So just really briefly speaking, I know that obviously the WHO recommends women to breastfeed for a certain amount of time. It just so happens that that recommendation
这非常重要。实际上，我们知道世界卫生组织建议母乳喂养是为了给孩子最好的成长机会，因为它最能满足他们的需求。我们将会有另一期节目，你和我专门讨论母乳喂养以及你对南亚女性母乳喂养的研究。所以如果人们想听那个，请留意本播客的下一期节目，很快就会推出。但这不仅仅是母乳喂养和相关问题，心理健康护理远不止于此。你能给我们更多见解，关于如果我们试图更好地服务于我们所合作的人群的需求，
is worded exactly in the Quran as a recommendation when it talks about breastfeeding. And it made me think that, for example, for someone that's not born in England, that hasn't been brought up maybe through Western education or isn't even familiar with the word the organization who to see it to note for a health care provider to then say well you know culturally if you look at your religious book the quran it says word for word what's written there's more influence coming from that source as opposed to who for certain people absolutely
我们应该开始考虑什么吗，Zainab？当我与朋友和家人谈论我这个特殊的兴趣时，我想到的一点是，你实际上在哪里进行这些干预，或者在哪里宣传关于照顾心理健康的信息。我想我的一个朋友在谈论她婆婆时，她是锡克教徒，比我们大两代。我朋友说，像创伤知情课程、小组干预，或者关于在需要支持时去哪里寻求服务的教育内容，如果以一种好的方式进行，比如在她每周五或每天都会去的地方，
it's really important and actually you know what we know with who is that breastfeeding is supposed to give the child the best chance to to kind of thrive because it optimally meets their needs we're going to have a separate episode where you and i talk about um specifically kind of breastfeeding um and your research in breastfeeding for South Asian women. So if people are wanting to listen to that, please do listen out for probably the next episode of this podcast that's coming soon. But this is, you know, mental health care is more than just breastfeeding and kind of the issues related to that. Could you kind of give us any more insights into how if we're trying to better serve the needs of the people that we are working with,
而且已经去了很多年了，她更有可能倾听，将其视为可信的信息来源，并真正注意所说的话，而不是去全科医生（GP）诊所进行常规预约，然后医生递给她一张传单，或者在咨询过程中提到它。尽管我们都知道全科医生有资格、受过教育，有能力提出这些建议，但在他们视为舒适区的地方进行这些交流，而且他们已经去了很多年，对于这些人来说，可信度更高。
what we might begin to think about, Zainab? One thing that came up for me when I was just talking about this particular interest of mine with friends and family and things is where you actually do these interventions or where you do where you promote the messages about you know looking after your mental health I think one of my friends was talking about say for their mother-in-law who's probably a couple of generations older of Sikh religion one thing that my friend was saying is that things like trauma-informed classes or like group interventions or even just educational content in regards to what services to go to when you need support and things like that I remember my friend saying was that if that was done in a good way where she goes every single Friday or every single day of the week anyway
比去全科医生诊所要高。我认为对我来说，我渴望知道的一点是——显然这需要进行研究——是将临床干预带入更具文化安全性的空间，我可能会称之为社区中心、清真寺或其他礼拜场所。我认为我读到过类似的内容，这应该被广泛研究和测试，看看改变实际提供干预或传递信息的人是否会有帮助。是的，这就像我们需要一些具有文化代表性的外展服务，真正审视我们所服务的人群的人口统计数据。你知道，我知道我的孩子
and has done for the last however many years more she's more likely to listen and to see as a credible source of information and to actually take notice of what's being said than if she is visiting say a GP surgery for a general appointment and there's leaflets or the GP themselves hands over a leaflet or brings it up during a during a consultation it's even though we all know that the GP has qualifications and is educated and qualified enough to make those recommendations but having it done in a place where they see as their sort of almost place of comfort and they've just been going there for years and years and years there's just more credibility for those sorts of individuals
上的学校有50%是英语作为第二语言（ESOL）的学生，那么我们在那所学校如何尝试以一种代表这种背景的方式进行沟通？当我们提供医疗服务时，我们如何看待人们的传统、文化和背景？我们不能仅仅期望人们来到我们所在的地方。我们不能仅仅提供一种“一刀切”的服务。我之前在播客中说过，我知道在伯明翰，实际上有相当多的华人人口。然而，我在伯明翰工作的近四年里，从未见过任何华人背景的人。那么，是服务没有吸引那个背景的人，还是这是一种文化问题，他们不知道这项服务，或者进入这项服务存在某种污名？我想这就是研究发挥作用的地方，
than there is for those going to the GP surgery I think it's about for me the one thing that I'm keen to know and obviously it would just require the research to be done but is to take the clinical interventions into more culturally safe spaces I'd probably call it like community centers, mosques, other places of worship and I think one thing I read was kind of similar to this is I think there should be widely looked into and widely tested as to whether changing who's actually delivering the intervention or delivering the message would help. Yeah it's almost like we need some culturally representative outreach to really look at the demographics of the populations that we serve you know so I know that my children
它让我们更好地审视我们在做什么，我们在服务谁，以及我们没有服务谁。是的，我认为这是你所说的一切的总结。我认为服务需要做更多的工作来接触那些总是被认为是“难以接触”的人。我实际上并不认为他们难以接触，我只是认为接触他们的方法并不总是正确的。所以他们总是被归类为难以接触。但另一方面，对于实际的服务用户或研究参与者，他们对心理学研究是什么、他们认为影响是什么，存在巨大的脱节。我认为，对于不同的族裔群体，当他们被视为少数群体时，有时存在一种风险，当提到
go to a school that has kind of 50% ESOL and so how are we trying to for example in that school look at communicating in a way that represents that and when we're delivering health services how are we looking at people's heritage their their culture, their background? And we can't just expect people to come to us where we are. We can't necessarily just deliver a one-size-fits-all service. And I've spoken on the podcast before that I know in Birmingham, there was actually quite a high Chinese population. And yet, I had never in my almost four years of working in Birmingham ever seen somebody of Chinese heritage and so is that the service just not attracting people from that background is this a culture thing that they're not aware of the service or that there's kind of stigma against them entering the service and I think it's it's I guess that's where research comes in
“研究”和“我们正在探索你的心理健康状况”这些词时，这几乎被视为“哦，他们是在看热闹”。这被视为一件非常负面的事情。我认为，如果以一种更被接受的方式向该人群提供更多信息，他们自己会更理解你的出发点。我认为这只是关于不同的视角没有对齐，所以你总是会发生冲突。我经常想到的一点是，在当今时代，我们如此多地转向社交媒体和在线，让一切都在线化，因为这更方便。但我认为这样做，你也孤立了一个根本没有在线概念、对在线不感兴趣的群体，特别是
that it lets us look better at what we're doing and who we're serving and who we are not serving yeah I think it's a culmination of everything that you've said I think services need to do more to engage with the what's always considered as hard to reach I actually don't think they're hard to reach I just think the approach to reach isn't always correct. So then always going to be classified as hard to reach. But then there's also from the other side, the actual service users or the research participants, there is such a disconnect in what they even think psychological research is, what they think the impact is is I think often with different ethnic groups when they're seen as such a minority I think sometimes there's a risk of when it's words
那些不是最初来自英国的人，在他们家乡的文化中，电力并不那么方便。我知道例如在巴基斯坦，当你去村庄时，电力不是理所当然的，他们经常停电。所以对他们来说，在线并不像对我这样。所以，虽然我可能会在社交媒体上看到易于消化的内容，并且我知道如何使用谷歌来查找我需要的信息，但有一大群人根本不知道。所以我认为，对转向这种在线生活和让一切
like research and we're exploring what's going on with your mental health it can almost be seen as oh they're like a spectacle it's seen as such a negative thing when I think again if like more information was given in a more accepted way to that population group they'll they themselves would understand more what perspective you're coming from I think it is just about different perspectives aren't almost aligning up so you're always kind of butting heads and I think one thing I think about a lot is that with obviously the day and age we're in we move so much to all social media and online and making everything online because it's more convenient but I think by doing that you're also icing a group that has no concept of being online has no interest in being online especially
数字化存在过多的依赖，这几乎使许多人面临被完全孤立于许多心理服务和许多一般医疗服务之外的风险。这是一个很好的观点，不是吗？当我们试图让每个人都转向“随时随地就诊”的预约时，这是否真的对每个人都理想？当然，如果感觉没有一个安全的空间，或者如果家庭环境实际上是问题的一部分，那么从远程环境谈论这些问题可能感觉不合适。我在印度广泛旅行过
ones that don't come from England originally when within their own cultures back home you know when electricity isn't so convenient um i know for example in pasadena when you go to villages and things you know like electricity isn't a thing they've got power outages all the time so for them being online just isn't the same as it is for say myself and so where i'm likely to see digestible content on social media and i'm likely to i know how to use google to find out information I need you've got a whole host of people that have absolutely no idea so I think there's almost a I think there's almost too much of a reliance on moving towards this online life and making
在2008年。实际上，至少在我看来，任何有心理健康问题的人似乎都被留下来自生自灭。我不知道这是否真的是这样，但在文化上，对有心理健康问题的人可能存在污名。你能为我们阐明一下这个方面吗？是的，当然。我的意思是，几代人以来，心理健康在许多南亚文化中都不是一个被谈论的话题。因为我不是印度人，我当然不能代表印度文化，但我知道巴基斯坦文化，尽管我们有很多相似之处，但情况是一样的，它就是不被谈论。特别是谈到女性，当涉及到产后抑郁症或产后精神病
everything digital that's almost putting a lot of people at risk of being completely isolated from a lot of psychological services and a lot of just healthcare services in general. That's a really good point, isn't it? As we try and move everybody towards attend-anywhere appointments, whether that actually is ideal for everybody. And of course, if there doesn't feel like there's a safe space or if actually the home environment is part of the problem, it might not feel like it's appropriate to be talking about those issues from a remote setting. I traveled quite extensively in India
之类的事情时，甚至连想都不会想。它甚至不是产后护理的一部分，它甚至不被认为是一回事。如果说有什么的话，在我们的文化中，对成为一个好母亲和社区中的母亲有太多的强调。以至于如果你偏离了那个“黄金标准”，而不是去看看是什么导致了这种情况，我们如何帮助你回到这个黄金标准，你就会被排斥。这就像你出了什么问题，你不适合做母亲。我知道，例如，我最近读到关于死产的研究，经历过死产的女性，
in 2008. And actually, it looked like to me anyway, that anybody with mental health problems was just kind of left to fend for themselves. I don't know if that's actually the case, but kind of culturally there may be a stigma towards people with mental health problems could you kind of illuminate that aspect a little bit for us yeah so certainly I mean for generations and generations mental health isn't a topic spoken about within a lot of South Asian cultures being that I'm not Indian I can't certainly say for Indian culture but I know for Pakistani culture although we share a lot of similarities it is the same it's just not spoken about speaking about women in particular when it comes to things like postnatal depression or postnatal psychosis
我认为这项研究是在巴基斯坦的农村地区进行的。经历过死产的女性，她们指出的事情之一是，她们被视为“杀婴者”，这简直就是所使用的词汇。她们受到了社区成员非常非常严重的污名化。我认为，尽管那项研究是在巴基斯坦的农村地区进行的，但它很容易渗透到英国，当你得到那些背景的人搬到这里并在这里建立家庭时，那种思维方式会代代相传。绝对是这样。我们怎么能认为这不会影响某人呢？
anything like that not even a thought it's not even part of the aftercare it's not even considered a thing and if anything within our culture anyway there's so much emphasis put on being a good mother and being a mother within your community that almost if you sort of defer from that gold standard instead of looking at okay what's actually might be causing that how can we help bring you back up to this golden standard you're just outcasted it's it's like there's something wrong with you you're not fit to be a mother um and i know that for example a lot of i read research recently on um stillbirth women that have experienced stillbirth um and i think this research was done in rural areas of pakistan
是的，这让我想起我在学校时，我的一个好朋友是印度教徒。对她和她妈妈来说，当她们月经来潮时，她们不应该进厨房，因为
and the women that had experienced stillbirth one of the things that they pointed out was that they were just seen as child killers that was literally the words that were used um and they were really really stigmatized by members of the community and I think again that can very easily although that research was done in rural areas of Pakistan it can so easily be seeped into the UK when you get people that come from those backgrounds that move here and build their families here that's just going to keep getting passed down generation that sort of that way of of thinking absolutely and how could we think that wouldn't affect somebody you know yeah it's making me think about when I was at school and one of my good friends was Hindu and for her and her mum when they were menstruating when they're on their period they weren't supposed to go in the kitchen because
这被视为“不洁”，她们不应该碰食物。对我来说，这很难理解。我在那个阶段为我的家人做了大量的烹饪。我们是否理解或同意并不重要。我们只需要意识到这一点，并理解对于我们合作的人来说，这很重要。关于月经或任何更广泛的文化、信仰和信念问题，还有什么可能是那个背景之外的人不知道的吗？首先想到的是关于月经，
it was seen as as being unclean and they shouldn't touch food. That was, for me, hard to get my head around. I did loads of cooking at that stage in my life for my family. It doesn't necessarily matter if we understand it or agree with it. We kind of just need to be aware of it and understand that for the person we're working with, that has importance. Is there anything else around, know menstruation or any wider issues for kind of cultures and faiths and beliefs that that perhaps somebody not of that heritage would not know about to actually come to mind the first one is actually in relation to menstruation so
虽然在我的文化和宗教中，那种特定的做法并不存在，但我听说过它。但关于——我是穆斯林，所以显然每年有一段时间我们要禁食30天。作为女性，如果你在这30天内的任何时候月经来潮，你不应该禁食，你会得到休息的时间。但我知道，这与宗教本身无关，宗教经文中没有任何地方提到这一点，但它被很多来自家庭内部的文化信仰所延续。这些家庭中的女性，很多时候几乎被迫感到她们必须向男性亲属或男性家庭成员和朋友隐瞒她们正在月经的事实。我以前读过一些故事，女性觉得她们需要假装自己在禁食，
whilst within my culture and religion that particular practice isn't a thing I have heard of it before but with regards to I'm a Muslim so obviously there's a period of time every year where we fast for 30 days and as a woman if you're menstruating at any point during those 30 days you're not supposed to fast you're given that time to have a break but I know and this has got nothing to do with the actual religion perpetuating it it's not mentioned anywhere in religious scriptures but it is perpetuated a lot by cultural beliefs that have just come from within families women within those families a lot of them are often almost made to feel like they have to hide the fact that they're menstruating from male relatives or male family members and friends and i've read stories before where women feel like they need to pretend that they are fasting
仅仅是为了保全面子。我认为像这样的事情，显然对于不来自那种文化的人来说，甚至你提到的那个，会非常奇怪。我认为有时如果这些经历在医疗环境中被讨论，你总是面临临床医生或医疗保健提供者将其视为“压迫性”的风险，或者使用某些语言，我认为这真的会破坏实际讲述的叙事。因为对于你的朋友来说，这可能不被视为压迫性或奇怪的，这对她们来说只是正常的。但当她们被一个不是同一族裔或背景的人喂养，并且完全不知道，使用诸如“那太压迫、太控制了”之类的词时，它真的会以一种非常负面的方式开始破坏叙事。我想到的第二个问题是，当你提到那个问题时，
just for the sake of saving face and things I think stuff like that obviously for someone that doesn't come from that culture and even the the one that you mentioned would be so strange and I think sometimes if those experiences are discussed within a healthcare setting you always have the risk of the clinician or the healthcare provider almost seeing it as oppressive or using certain language like that which I think can really mess with the narrative that's actually being told because for your friend for example that may not be seen as oppressive or as strange or anything of the sort that's just normal for them but when they're then almost being fed by someone else who's not of the same ethnicity or heritage and no idea using you know words like well that's quite
我实际上认为这在现在相比以前被广泛讨论了。但对于我的背景或同一宗教的人来说，我们从宗教角度被邀请做的一件事是几乎以“耳语”的方式祈祷。所以从外面看，可能看起来我们只是在自言自语，但实际上是在祈祷，同时也在移动嘴唇。我知道，再次从阅读网上的故事以及我有在医疗环境中工作的家庭成员来看，风险之一是当你有一个病人或服务
oppressive controlling it can really start to mess the narrative in a really negative way and the second one that came to mind when you mentioned that question was um i actually think this is quite widely spoken about now in comparison to what it was before um but for people of my heritage or people of my same religion one of the things that we're invited to do from a religious perspective is almost make prayers under sort of like a whispered tongue so to the outside it might look like we're just talking to ourselves but it's almost making prayer but with moving them off at the same time and I know again from reading just stories online and from I've got family members that work in the healthcare settings and things one of the risks of that is when you have a patient or a service
用户与他们的宗教联系如此紧密时，他们可能会使用与他们的宗教信仰相关的表达方式，或者他们可能正在进行那种低声祈祷的做法。但这也可能被视为“自言自语”，这显然开始与不同的心理障碍和心理健康问题交织在一起。我认为，同样地，宗教行为或文化行为开始被视为压迫和控制，你也会面临宗教行为被视为“某人在自言自语”或“他们听到声音”之类的风险。所以，我认为从一个
user that is so strongly connected to their religion they might use expressions that are related to their their religious beliefs or they might be doing that practice of making a prayer under their tongue or under their breath but that also can be seen as talking to themselves which obviously then starts to weave into different psychological disorders and mental health problems and I think again similarly to religious practices or cultural practices that then start to be seen as oppressive and controlling you then also have the risk of just religious acts being seen as someone's talking to themselves or they're hearing voices and things like that so again I think from a
如果一个人与他们的宗教信仰联系非常紧密，他们可能会使用与宗教信仰相关的表达方式，或者他们可能会在舌尖下或低声进行祈祷，但这在旁人看来也可能被视为自言自语，而这显然又开始与各种心理障碍和心理健康问题挂钩。我认为，同样地，宗教习俗或文化习俗一旦开始被视为压迫性和控制性的，那么单纯的宗教行为也有可能被误认为是某人在自言自语，或者听到幻听之类的，所以我觉得从一个
researcher's point of view a psychological practitioner's point of view there has to be such a strong knowledge or not even a knowledge but just an acceptance of that there are such stark differences across different cultures that it's not always such a negative thing or don't always jump to sort of the dsm and trying to match the things up i think if we if there's more time taken just to understand what is the whole picture what is their day-to-day life what is the practices that they engage in there'll be a lot more of a complete story I think sorry to keep rambling on but another thing that made me think just then is I remember that I have a friend that did a midwife course and one of her clients was again South
从研究者的角度，或者心理从业者的角度来看，必须要有非常深刻的认知，甚至不需要是认知，仅仅是接受这样一个事实：不同文化之间存在着巨大的差异，这并不总是一件负面的事情。不要总是急于套用DSM（精神疾病诊断与统计手册）去生搬硬套。我认为，如果我们能花更多时间去了解全貌，了解他们的日常生活，了解他们所参与的习俗，我们就能得到一个更完整的故事。抱歉我一直在唠叨，但刚才又让我想起一件事，我记得我有个朋友参加了助产士课程，她的客户中有一位又是南亚人，
Asian didn't speak very good English and so their partner was the person that was in the room with them as their almost representative and spokesperson. However, you could tell that the partner wasn't really interested in any of the aftercare when it came to talking about psychological care. And obviously, I think my friend was trying to get across information about, you know, if you experience this, if you feel like this, you need to report to this service and things like that. And for obviously the lady, no understanding of what's this service and things like that and for obviously the lady no understanding of what's being said and also her partner decided to not go ahead with an interpreter and took on that role himself but obviously once again when you allow things like that to happen within healthcare you run the risk of they're not translating the right information across and I think again for that example it just made me think so for those two individuals mental health care just wasn't a I thought it
英语说得不太好，所以她的伴侣作为她的代表和发言人陪在房间里。然而，你可以看出，当谈到心理护理时，这位伴侣对任何后续护理都不感兴趣。显然，我的朋友试图传达一些信息，比如，如果你经历了这些，如果你有这种感觉，你需要向这个服务机构报告等等。而对于这位女士来说，她显然不了解什么是这种服务，而且她的伴侣决定不使用翻译，而是自己承担了这个角色。但显然，当你允许在医疗保健中发生这样的事情时，你就会冒着他们无法准确传达信息的风险。我认为再次回到那个例子，它只是让我想到，对于那两个人来说，心理健康护理根本就不是一个……我想它
wasn't even something to consider so for the gentleman who was supposed to be that woman's advocate and taking on that information translating it in something that she could understand he wasn't doing that because it just and I don't think it was even in a malicious way I think it generally was because for him it just wasn't something of importance so again for me that just brings up the importance of we have to sort of approach different target populations in a way that suits them absolutely and i think as a service provision issue in the service i most recently worked in an adult mental health we didn't allow anyone to interpret other than our official interpreting service just so that we've got our best chance, hopefully, of engaging
甚至不是一个需要考虑的问题。所以对于那位本应是那位女士的倡导者，并负责将信息翻译成她能理解的内容的男士来说，他并没有这样做，因为这对他来说根本不重要，而且我不认为他是出于恶意，我认为这纯粹是因为对他而言，这根本不是什么重要的事情。所以对我来说，这再次提出了一个重要性，即我们必须以适合不同目标人群的方式去接触他们。当然，作为一项服务提供问题，在我最近工作的成人心理健康服务中，我们不允许除官方翻译服务以外的任何人进行翻译，这样我们才能有最好的机会去接触到某人，而不是让问题持续恶化。
someone and not perpetuating problems. Zainab, it's been absolutely fascinating speaking with you. Thank you so much for talking with us about this. And like I said, we are going to be doing another episode together where we talk more specifically about your research into breastfeeding with South Asian women. But thank you so much for your time today. It's been really illuminating and I hope this will be really, really helpful for people. If people wanted to come and connect or learn more about you or your research, where's the best place for them to do that? Is it LinkedIn? Yes, I would say LinkedIn. I do plan to have a Twitter account at some point down the line for research purposes,. That will come as
Zainab，和你交谈真是太令人着迷了。非常感谢你和我们谈论这个话题。正如我所说，我们将一起制作另一期节目，专门讨论你关于南亚女性母乳喂养的研究。但非常感谢你今天抽出时间。这真的很有启发性，我希望这对人们真的非常有帮助。如果人们想联系你或了解更多关于你或你的研究的信息，最好的方式是什么？是LinkedIn吗？是的，我会说是LinkedIn。我确实计划在未来的某个时候为了研究目的开设一个Twitter账户，那会是……
of when. But yeah, LinkedIn would probably be the best place to start with. Perfect. Thank you so much for your time, Zainab. Thank you. Oh, thank you so much for your time, Zainab. It's interesting that after we stopped recording and we're waiting for the uploads to happen, we were talking about imposter syndrome and how for Zainab and for myself as well, sometimes you have those moments of, oh, who am I to be doing this? And I definitely have that. I'm definitely on board with that. And that is something that I spoke about in episode 155 of this podcast, thinking about imposter syndrome and how we can win that battle. But Zainab was saying really from being quite a recent graduate to then suddenly being on this podcast and having you know a platform to explore these really key and important issues you know it just takes a
到时候再说。但是的，LinkedIn可能是最好的起点。太完美了。非常感谢你抽出时间，Zainab。谢谢。哦，非常感谢你抽出时间，Zainab。有趣的是，在我们停止录音并等待上传时，我们谈到了冒名顶替综合症，以及对于Zainab和我自己来说，有时会有那种“哦，我是谁，我凭什么做这些？”的时刻。我绝对有这种感觉。我完全认同这一点。这也是我在本播客第155集中谈到的内容，思考冒名顶替综合症以及我们如何赢得这场战斗。但Zainab说，从一个刚毕业不久的学生，突然来到这个播客，拥有一个平台来探索这些非常关键和重要的问题，这真的需要……
little moment to kind of catch your breath and and kind of see where you're at and I have that all the time as well you know I might be about to do some tv work or to go live on the radio and you're thinking it's just little old me but it's really important that we feel the fear and we do it anyway. So yeah, with that in mind, if you've got an interesting topic that you think would make a great episode, please do get in contact with me. I would love your thoughts around this episode. Please do like, comment, engage, share this with anyone you think might find it helpful. Perhaps your staff team, perhaps your family, perhaps friends, people that you think might find it helpful. Perhaps your staff team, perhaps your family, perhaps friends, people that you think might find it really useful or might feel seen,
花一点时间来喘口气，看看自己处于什么位置。我一直也有这种感觉，你知道，我可能正要去做一些电视工作，或者去电台直播，你会想“这只是渺小的我”，但重要的是我们要感受恐惧，然后依然去做。所以，考虑到这一点，如果你有一个你认为会成为精彩节目的有趣话题，请务必联系我。我很想听听你对这一集的看法。请点赞、评论、参与、分享给任何你认为可能会觉得有帮助的人。也许是你的员工团队，也许是你的家人，也许是朋友，那些你认为可能会觉得它真的很有用，或者可能会感到被看见、
might feel heard by this episode. If you are watching this as an aspiring psychologist, please do check out my books, The Aspiring Psychologist Collective and The Clinical Psychologist Collective. And if it's your time and you're ready for the next step, the Aspiring Psychologist Membership, we are doing beautiful things in there. We are helping people to up their game in research, in CBT skills and formulation, in interview skills, in application form skills, in self-belief. People often say to me that it feels like I hold the
可能会因为这一集而感到被倾听的人。如果你正在以有抱负的心理学家的身份观看此节目，请务必查看我的书《有抱负的心理学家集体》和《临床心理学家集体》。如果时机成熟，你准备好迈出下一步了，欢迎加入“有抱负的心理学家会员”，我们在那里做着美好的事情。我们正在帮助人们提升他们在研究、CBT技能和构思、面试技巧、申请表技巧以及自信心方面的水平。人们经常对我说，感觉就像是我在他们无法为自己坚持下去时，为他们保留了希望。
hope for them when they can't hold it for themselves. And we are doing brilliant things and getting real tangible results for people in their psychology careers. You can join for just £30 a month with no minimum commitment commitment if you wanted to join for a longer period of time you can join for six months where you get a free 30 minute one-to-one with me if you wanted to join for a year and pay up front you get two 30 minute one-to-ones with me or your choice of a one hour one-to-one as well for more information please do check out my website otherwise thank you so much for watching for listening for spending your time with me one-to-one as well. For more information, please do check out my website. Otherwise, thank you so much for watching, for listening, for spending your time with me and with Zainab. Thank you so much. Take care and be kind to yourself. Let this be your guide. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified.
我们正在做着出色的工作，并为人们的心理学职业生涯带来切实可见的成果。你每月只需支付30英镑即可加入，没有最低承诺。如果你想加入更长的时间，你可以加入六个月，届时你将获得一次免费的30分钟一对一咨询；如果你想加入一年并预付费用，你将获得两次30分钟的一对一咨询，或者选择一次一小时的一对一咨询。欲了解更多信息，请查看我的网站。否则，非常感谢你的观看、收听，感谢你与我共度时光。欲了解更多信息，请查看我的网站。否则，非常感谢你的观看、收听，感谢你与我以及Zainab共度时光。非常感谢。保重，善待自己。让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。
It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. my name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是由Marianne Trent博士主持的《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我叫Jana，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书，我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历真的非常有趣。成为临床心理学家有这么多不同的途径，这让我感到惊讶，而且没有完美的途径，这让我充满了信心，不再觉得自己做错了，也减轻了自己的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来了。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。